whether you deploy applications and
monitor operations design and manage
Cloud architecture Solutions or
configure and run sap workloads learn
about Google Cloud's approach to
infrastructure and implementing
deploying migrating and maintaining
applications with the infrastructure
modernization learning path this path
was designed to guide you no matter
where you are in your Learning Journey
start at the first stop if you're new to
Google cloud or jump in at a different
stop if you're enhancing an existing
skill set
along the way earn skill Badges and
prepare to become Google Cloud certified
the first few stops will help you learn
the fundamentals of core infrastructure
and architecting with Google compute
engine
in addition depending on your role and
the track you choose learn about Google
kubernetes engine design and process and
deploying sap
learn from Google Cloud experts via
instructor-led training or take
advantage of the flexibility of
on-demand the choice is completely up to
you Google Cloud offers multiple
modalities so you can learn how you want
to whether on demand or instructor-led
you will gain access to the same course
content in Labs so you won't miss out on
a hands-on experience
practice what you've learned polish your
skills and earn skill badges show the
world that you and your team can create
manage automate administer and deploy
Cloud resources environments and
infrastructure use skill badges to gain
recognition or to help you land a new
role next up it's time to prepare to
become Google Cloud certified by taking
the instructor-led or on-demand course
and checking out the various guides and
Sample exam questions
once you pass the exam you're officially
a certified professional Cloud engineer
or architect on Google Cloud looking to
continue learning or for a different
topic area Google Cloud offers learning
paths spanning across the solution
pillars
from beginner to Advanced this
comprehensive learning path will guide
you along your Google Cloud
infrastructure and modernization
Learning Journey time to get started